Since you guys went at it with the wall
The thing is, this isn't aluminum.
I've been waiting to do this for so long.
Yeah!
This is sweet
Hit here and then hang on it!
Wow. I'm actually a little impressed.
Here, you guys want to do an axe-throwing contest?
Remember, we used have to suggest the idea of a plasma grenade more than show a
real-life plasma grenade.
So, hopefully I can build something that we can just like
save as a preset and just load in every
single comp.
-Let's start with just 2D tracking everything
-Okay.
[laughs]
-Wikka-Wikka-Wa!
-He's freakin' out, dude.
-He's freaking out more than you are right now
-Yeah.
You should really tone it back John. Stop freaking out.
-John, calm down.
-I'm sorry.
I love Particular so much.
What I do is I have them start at like 0%
scale and the longer that particle
exists
the bigger it gets. And I also invert
that for opacity.
And... hey! [laughs]
You could have told me you were rolling!
John here cranking away on muzzle
flashes. I just started going through and
dropping in plasma grenades and stuff
we will see how the next four days ago
and-
-It's his birthday
Oh, who's this beanie from? Why it's from our
friends at Flite Test. They sent me a free hat
Nico, you get all the Flite Test swag!
So I legitimately like split my lip last
night when I tried to bite the lens
Rahh! Augh!
Ow! Augh.
Then stop it and go to the bathroom.
What are you talking about? We'll be
here for the next few hours.
No, cut it and go to the bathroom;
I don't want to be waiting on you, like,
being like 'ahh I gotta go!'
So I don't think John's coming in
today...
[brooding music]
Yeah no, I think John may be sick
Day 4 of 6- day 4 of 5. 'Cause Nico said we
should get it done in five
But I mean that makes sense, just so we
can use that final day for like, you know,
polish and whatnot. I think we're
actually on track to do that!
You can put the camera away now...
Please?
I'm not tired right now.
I left here around 12:30. Just
starting to get into a groove
Brandon Alex and Niko come in; they're like "We're going
to set up the Vive".
I was like 'Well, maybe I'll just play a couple games".
Before I take a look let's also get the face... the actual face thing in.
Get the ugliest baby you can.
Make its eyes go outwards and make him go 'heyyy'.
The main reason why effects need to be done
today is so that I can move on to other things, however
We have time.
That's the thing, I'm not worried.
Yeah, I mean kind of, technically. Maybe.
I think we're on schedule.
The difference- Okay...
I don't know man. I don't know if
everything is going to be one hundred
percent hands off done by
the end of the day
[laughs] Yes!
Bustin' it all out!
Woooo!
[music]
Gotta axe somebody!
So... we did all of that without any eye
protection.
Never do that, always wear eye protection, we are idiots.
-Pffft!
You want to be an intern?!
Apply now!
ARRRG
I really only do VR when I'm fucked up.